Musica So, wir beginnen mit einem Song, ich singe, Stefan steigt irgendwann ein, dann kommt das Intro, dann kommen die Top 5, dann kommt Stefans Anekdote, dann kommt noch dreimal das Intro, dann kommen die nächsten Top 5 und dann kommt Motherfucking Freestyle.
Hier ist der Song. in the sea, you can make me whole again. Ich dachte, während ich... Wir machen es nochmal. Ich kenne den Song nicht. Ich kenne den Song ja, aber ich kenne den Lurys. Während ich weiter singe, fängst du an zu moderieren. Alles klar. Okay. So ist man den Senderablauf vorher auch ausdrucken, habe ich schon mal gesagt. Drei, vier. I wanna stand with you on a mountain. I wanna lay with you in the sea. You can make me whole again. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietzwe und das ist Florentin Wille. Wir freuen uns, Sie zu einer neuen Folge zu Das Podcast-UFO begrüssen zu dürfen. Heute mit dem Gepäck spannende Anekdoten von A wie Analphabeten bis Z wie das große Zebra-Abenteuer von Florentin aus dem Zoo mit dem Wandertag der Klasse 9b in den Zoo. Wollen wir anfangen, damit die Gründe aufzuzählen, warum die Folge heute nicht so gut wird? Wir fangen erstmal an. Die Top 100, präsentiert von Booster Energy James. Top 5. Erstmal auf Platz 5 der Gründe, warum die Folge heute nicht so gut wird. Wir sind in einem anderen Raum als sonst, und zwar sind wir immer entweder per Skype verbunden oder im Tonstudio zusammen. Wir sind im Gefängnis. Wir sind heute im Gefängnis. Das ist einige schiefgelaufen. Ich sag mal, Stephans Flirt-Tipps aus Folge 37 kam dann beim schönen Geschlecht nicht ganz so gut an. Und er hat mich da irgendwie mit reingeritten. Deswegen. Ding, ding, ding. Wobei, so schön war das Geschlecht in diesem Fall auch gar nicht. Du musst du wissen, wenn deine Mutter zuhört, ich will sie nicht beleidigen. Sehr gut. Und das war der beste Gang dieser Folge. Schleiten Sie jetzt ab. Sie haben ihn sicher. Auf Platz Nummer vier, nee, Platz Nummer fünf kommen wir mal. Wir sind heute im Proberaum der Band Die Freie Radikale im Neomagazinstudio, was ein bisschen weird ist, und ich glaube, das ist das Verbot, was du gerade machst. Und ich glaube, das könnte anwaltliche Konsequenzen haben, dass wir es jetzt mit aufgenommen haben, dass Florentinas Schlagzeug der Marke Tama benutzt hat. Herr Tizze. Sie sind ja... Wollen wir mal vielleicht erklären, was wir hier alles so sehen? Wir sind ja gerade... Also ich glaube, wir sind auch deshalb so ein bisschen holprig jetzt hier eingestiegen, weil wir einfach so eine Reizüberflutung gerade erleben. Das stimmt. Und hier sind so ganz viele Poster und das ist genau das. Ich habe ja früher auch in einer Band gespielt und der Popperraum sah ähnlich aus. Wie wir hießen? Ganzen Roses. Wir hatten eine gute Zeit. Macht jetzt nicht mehr? Ne, sind wir nicht mehr so gut dabei. Warum? Wie ist das auseinandergegangen? Ach, der Sänger war dann irgendwann auch tot, ich weiß es nicht. Irgendwann gestorben. Gestorben. Ja, genau, gestorben. Okay, ist gestorben. Wir sind ein sehr schlechter Interviewer, der immer versucht, dass die Frage noch gerade richtig gestellt wird. Er ist, die hat ihre Mutter liest bereit. Oder so ein Anwalt, der sich auf den Fall nicht vorbereitet hat. Sie haben den Angeklagten getötet, getötet, getötet, getötet, ja, das reicht doch natürlich, haben sie ihn getötet. Und so einen breiten Grinsen dann seinen Mörder verteidigt. Ja, wo der Angeklagte auch hilft.. Der Gang kommt nicht so gut rüber, Audi. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Hier, himmauzt, kann man auch nicht überringen. Du sagst eben, dass wir nicht gut visuell rüberkommen. Heißt das, du möchtest in Zukunft schon gern auf die Leinwand, auf die Kinoleinwand? Nein. Das Podcast-Ufer der Film, wir überspringen einfach drei Schritte. Du hast ja Kartoffelsalat nicht gesehen in Filmen. Sechentlich nicht, nein. Wo man tatsächlich mal sehen kann. Ich weiß nicht, ist das wirklich ein Film, wo man zwei Folgen drüber reden sollte? Nein. Nee, erzähl dir ruhig. Wir haben ja, du wolltest ja eine neue Rubrik einführen, wo wir über Filme reden. Ja, gerne, wo wir über Filme reden. Einfach mal so ein bisschen Filme. Wah, wah, wah, wah,awawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawawaw Also wenn das geht und man hat folgende Wette, es gibt ja verschiedene Worte, die mehrere Bedeutungen haben, wie zum Beispiel das Wort Film, einmal als Tesafilm und einmal als den Film, den man im Kino sieht. Man hat immer eine 50-50-Chance. Und dann sollte einer der beiden dieses Wort sagen und der andere sollte erraten, welche Bedeutung gemeint ist. Das heißt, wir machen das jetzt mal, ich sage das Wort und du versuchst zu erraten, ob ich Tesafilm oder Kinofilm meine. Film. Also falls ihr draußen das jetzt wisst, sagt es laut. Du meinst den Film. Welchen? Du meinst den Bildschirmfilm. Nein. Aber das ist blöd zu sagen, wir wetten das, weil niemand weiss, woran du denkst. Das ist relativ einfach, die Wette gewinnen kannst. Er muss sich vorher aufschreiben. Die wird das relativ einfach, zu sagen,
ja, ich habe daran gedacht, was du meintest.
Das war unsere zweite Idee, an welche Zahl denke ich.
Eins oder zwei.
Eins oder
eins Komma eins. Die macht es euch sehr einfach.
Erstmal die Chance, dass man falsch liegt, nur 50 Prozent.
Sag mal top, die Wette gilt.
Moderier mal an. So, Florentin
Will aus Ebersbach bei München wettet, dass er Worte erkennen kann, in dem Fall, dass er... Indem er sie ausspricht oder aufschreibt. Und der andere, indem er mit ihnen etwas macht und der andere muss herausfinden, welche Bedeutung er meint. Genau, top, die Wette.
Ganz kurz, Tom Hanks, wie schätzen Sie die Chancen ein des jungen Florentin-Bittel, der 16 Jahre alt aus Ebersbach stammt? Naja, ich glaube, dass wie Shakespeare damals sagte, dass man sagt jedenfalls, dass die Wette zu bestehen, wir sie auf den Beinen gewinnen werden. Es ist ein schönes Land, ich bin gern hier, ich glaube auch, dass Florentin Willig aus Ebersbach diese Wette bestehen kann, nicht. Ich glaube, er schafft es nicht. Und falls er es schaffen sollte, bin ich recht, die Praktionen im Krieg im Felde zu besiegen, wie Breitchenke sagte. Viel Glück, du schaffst es nicht.
Film.
Du meinst die Leinwand, den Film auf der Leinwand.
Ja, richtig, ja, mit Kino!
Wie ist die Melodie?
Very good, my young friend. Very good, my friend. Oh, Tom Hanks, he's standing, he's dancing, he's coming down to shake the hand. What is he doing? He slipped, he fell, he fell, oh my God. Jetzt muss er seinen Wetteinsatz einlösen, er muss seinen Wetteinsatz einlösen, er muss jetzt im Film einen Behinderten spielen, der andauernd seine scheisse Pralinen-Schachtel hier unter die Nase hält. Jetzt trage ich ein Wort, und zwar Erde, und du musst sagen, mein ich den Planeten Erde oder das, was man beispielsweise bei Pflanzen in Töpfe reinmacht oder nicht?
An was denke ich?
Top, die Wette.
Ganz kurz, nur um mal die Technik zu verraten.
Was ich mache, ich sage das Wort zum Beispiel Blumen vor deinem Wort.
Also ich denke mir Blumenerde, Blumenerde und gucke dann, ob es zusammenpasst.
Oder die Erde, was natürlich.
Ich sage Blumenerde, wenn es nicht passt, weiß ich ja, dass die andere Erde gemeint ist. Ihr könnt doch draußen ruhig mitmachen, ne? Top, die Wette gilt. Blumen Warte, Blumen Erde. Blumen. Ne, war der Planet. Ja, was ist? Jawohl, zwei von zwei Versuchen, ey. Also, statistisch statistisch gesehen sind wir jetzt noch im grünen Bereich. Wollen wir es nochmal probieren? Wir versuchen noch einmal Filmen. Okay. Wenn wir das schaffen. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, beim zweiten Mal ist es ein bisschen schwieriger, finde ich, weil entweder er macht das gleiche nochmal, aber er wird es ein bisschen anders sagen, weil man kann nie ein Wort genau gleich aussprechen. Oder du sagst, um ein bisschen Diversität reinzubringen, nimmst du jetzt den Tesafilm. Ich bin gespannt. Tesafilm. Tesafilm. Der Film. Tesafilm. Film. Kann ich es nochmal hören? Film. Du meinst den Tesafilm. Wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, ich meine den Tesafilm. Nee.
Ich meine den Kinofilm.
Das war unsere Rubrik.
Film.
Was hältst du von meiner Filmidee?
Ein Typ, der ist selbstständig und er lebt verrückte Abenteuer. Nee, und der hat sich zum Beruf gemacht, dass er künstliche Intelligenzen testet. Das ist sein Job. Er geht zu Firmen, also der hat auch ganz hohes Ansehen in der Branche. Ja, ich will nicht gerade, ob es sicher so gut ist, das rauszuhauen. Wenn es jetzt eine gute Idee ist. Ja, ich versuche hier einen Podcast zu machen, Kollege. Wenn du da keinen Bock auf hast. Lassen wir es. Kommen wir mal zu deinen Anekdoten. Nein, ich bin jetzt bei einem Typen. Ich bin jetzt gerade voll bildlich vorgestellt. Seine Aufgabe ist es, er geht immer zu Firmen, zu IT-Firmen, die künstliche Intelligenzen erstellen und seine auch Zukunft. Schon in der Zukunft spielt er das eher, ne? Nein, eigentlich in der Echtzeit, in der Nahen Zukunft, sage ich mal. Und er geht da hin und dann muss er halt immer so den Turing-Test machen, also ob, wenn du dich mit einer künstlichen Intelligenz unterhältst, ob du merkst, dass es ein Mensch ist oder dass es kein Mensch ist, ob du merkst, dass es ein künstlicher Intelligenz ist.
Ja, okay.
Und dann geht er immer zu diesen Firmen irgendwie und dann unterhält er sich mit diesen künstlichen Intelligenzen und stellt dann eben immer so eine Bewertung raus an die Firma und aufgrund dieser Bewertung kann dann eben die Firma die künstliche Intelligenz verkaufen und verbessern, weil er halt der große Experte ist. Und dann spricht er eben mit dieser künstlichen Intelligenz und
ja, dann passiert irgendwas
Cooles.
Er verliebt sich in sie. Ja, genau, er verliebt sich
in sie und dann
gibt es allerdings, dann ist es
aber unglaubwürdig
und dann die Firma
patcht dann die Gefühle raus, dass die künstliche
Intelligenz keine Gefühle mehr haben soll und es gibt nur eine
Version und in die nächste Version verliebt er sich nicht mehr und er muss dann diese Version, in die er sich verliebt hat, suchen, die irgendwo in der Wüste von Nevada vergraben wurde. Die auf irgendeinem Server ist und es dauert wahnsinnig lange, die Hälfte des Films einfach nur runterlädt, Excel aufmacht. Es steht nur noch E. Fuck, ich hab keinen 3G mehr. Das ist im Grunde der ganze Film. Falls wir mitspielen wollen. Wobei ich mich bei dir auch vorstellen kann, dass die Hälfte des Films einfach so ein sich drehender Hamburger ist, der irgendwie auf so einem Tablett wahnsinnig gut aussieht, wahnsinnig gut ausgeleuchtet ist, auch einfach ganz lange dreht. Ja, ich musste mal in der Frank-Elster-Masterclass einen Beitrag zur Bundesliga machen. Ganz furchtbar, ich hasse Fußball und alles, was damit zu tun hat. Aber warum kann man Fußball hassen? Also was hat Fußball mit dir gemacht?
Naja, es ist einfach maximal
uninteressant. Das interessiert mich halt überhaupt nicht.
Bist du andere Sportart interessanter? Ja.
Beispiele? Also von der
Sportart eher, finde ich schon okay.
Aber jetzt dieses ganze Bundesliga
und welche Mannschaft, welcher Spieler und so, das ist mir
alles komplett egal. Und dann habe ich
auch so einen Beitrag gemacht und wusste nicht, wie ich aus dem Beitrag
rausgehen ging, weil der Beitrag ging so, ja, ich interessiere mich nicht für Fußball.
Und dann wusste ich nicht, wie man den Beitrag beenden soll. Das war ein sehr kurzer Beitrag, drei Sekunden. Ich wusste nicht, wie man den Beitrag beenden soll, deswegen habe ich am Ende einfach so ein Bild von so brutzeltem Speck, tragisch, zehn Sekunden lang und dann einfach so ausfaden lassen. Das war mein Beitrag, war nicht der Besser. Es gibt wahnsinnig gute Ideen in solchen Amateurfilmen manchmal.
Ich habe irgendwie, wir haben das immer mit Kumpels mal getroffen, haben dann alte Filme, die man in so Literaturkursen gemacht hat, damals in der fünften Klasse oder so, haben uns nochmal angeguckt. Und das war der Film war Bullshit total. Aber dann war der Abspann dann, mit toller Musik und Namen kam. Und dann hat der Cutter sich irgendwie betonen wollen im Abspann. Und das war der krasseste Effekt, den ich jemals in einem Film gesehen habe. Also Name kommt, Name kommt, coole Musik im Hintergrund, plötzlich kommt sein Name und die Musik mit dem Schnitt auf seinen Namen hört einfach auf. Und alle gucken auf den Fernseher, was ist jetzt los? Und die Musik fing halt wieder an, als ein anderer Name kam. Das ist der krasseste Effekt, das ist wahnsinnig schlau und wahnsinnig kreativ. Und wir dachten, wo ruht man denn dann in der Klasse, dann in der Stufe, diese Kreativität her.
Das ist schon ganz geil.
Und wir sassen davon und wir dachten, brilliant, und damit wird man sich auch vollhängen.
Ja, wir mussten damals in der achten Klasse auch Filme drehen im Musikunterricht.
Und einige von uns hatten kein Schnittprogramm, das heißt, wir hatten nur eine Kamera und mussten dann halt mit der Kamera schneiden.
Also halt einen Take aufnehmen, stoppen und dann halt beim nächsten Take anfangen.
Wie mit Wein heutzutage.
Und so weiter, wie ein Wein, genau. Das Problem war, dass halt nicht jede Szene im ersten Take geklappt hat. Das heißt, du hattest die Outtakes alle im Film drin. Manche Szenen wurden halt vier, fünf Mal gedreht und immer wieder angesetzt und die wurden nicht rausgeschnitten. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz geil, die Art einen Film zu erzählen. Weil du die nicht ernst nehmen kannst. Du hast die Samenproduktionen drin.
Und du kennst die Szene schon und du merkst, oh, es hat ein bisschen was verändert und so. Weil ich habe die Szene ein paar Mal gesehen. Und das war echt lustig. Das hat mir echt gut gefallen. War echt eine... Ja, finde ich lustig. Coole Zeit damals. Coole Zeit. Wollen wir mal aus der Filmrubrik raus, oder? Du, wir müssen die ab... Ja, komm, mach mal. Booster präsentiert. Das Podcast-UFO-Film. Ach Mensch, du, letzte Mittwoch ist mir was Verrücktes passiert. Davon muss ich dir unbedingt erzählen. Ja, ich bin gespannt. Ich gehe nur die Pointe. Ich weiß nicht, wie das die Geschichte beeinflusst. Und zwar, ich habe ja hier gedreht in Köln und bin direkt nach dem Dreh nach Hause gegangen, zum Hauptbahnhof, und dann auf der Einfahrt zum Studio. Ich laufe vor mich hin, völlig nichts ahnd, wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, dass eine fiese Plastikschlaufe in meinem Weg lag und ich bin gestürzt. Und ich bin tatsächlich auf sehr raum Boden gestürzt und es war echt so ein bisschen komisch, weil es war wie so ein Plastikkreis, tatsächlich so ein abgeschlossener Kreis und ich bin erst mit einem Fuss drin hängen geblieben und hatte dann so den Kreis um meinem Fuss und ich dachte, ja kein Problem, schüttel ich ab und in dieser Vorwärtsschüttelbewegung bin ich mit dem anderen Fuss auch noch reingeraten, war also komplett gefesselt und konnte es gar nicht glauben. Ich war in so einem, ach, das kann doch jetzt ein Überall, der ist ja schon sehr, sehr weit hergeholt. Der ist schon sehr Slapstick, was mir gerade passiert. Dass ich jetzt genau in die Schlaufe so laufe. Aber bist du so reflektiert, dass du dann in diesen Momenten so schon, wenn du dich nachdenkst? Ja. Ist das doch fast dieses Kommen, das die uns kaputt macht? Ja, absolut, aber ich dachte mir schon so, also das, ich hatte das Gefühl, oh shit, ich hänge fest, dachte mir dann aber, naja, das kann nicht sein, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das stattfindet. Und dann wollte ich so ein paar Schritte gehen, konnte nicht und war im Begriff zu stürzen und auch im Sturz dachte ich mir noch, ach Quatsch, also da bin ich... Das ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich, was mir gerade passiert hier. Da bin ich ja gleich wieder raus. Ich werde wahrscheinlich gleich wieder meinen Fuss befreien können und kann wieder stehen. Nope, bin weitergefallen und bin wirklich gestürzt. Und ich habe tatsächlich erst, als ich auf dem Boden aufgeschlagen bin, und es ist ja echt ein krasses Erlebnis, wenn du einfach so völlig ungebremst einfach noch vorne umfällst, aus, sag ich mal, meinen zwei Meter fünf... Ja, da fährt man ja Hände, wo man sich abstützt. Ja, Hände, und ich habe mir dann auch die... Aber du fällst ja nicht tief. Bei deinen 1,30. Ja, geht schon. Und ich habe mich dann auch in den Händen aufgestützt und mir die Hände auch aufgerissen, haben komplett geblutet, beide Hände. Hände geblutet. Hände geblutet. Und ich konnte ja nichts machen, ich konnte mich jetzt nicht verbinden oder so, dann habe ich mich halt abgetupft und bin halt weitergegangen zum Hauptbahnhof. Und man stand dann halt so auch in der U-Bahn und so und halt mit blutenden Händen. Kinder haben immer blutende Hände. Das ist der meiste der Welt. Wenn so Erwachsenen neben dir stehen, denkt man, oh, ist es Jesus? Der Visier ist zurückgekehrt. Das war auch so eine komische Situation irgendwie. Es hatte so ein bisschen was Animalisches. Ich habe dann auch mein iPhone in die Hand genommen und so ein bisschen rumgespielt und hatte so Blutschlieren auf meinem iPhone, was auch so ein cooler Moment war irgendwie so. Die organisierte Zivilisation, der technische Fortschritt, aber dieses animalisch dreckige Blut, diese Gewalt. Das sieht man ja sonst in Filmen auch, also Blut auf solchen technischen Geräten, sieht man ja sonst, die sind ja so rein, auch alle so Apple-Produkte sind so perfekt, wenn da so ein Blutschlierer drauf ist. Oder zum Beispiel auch die Szene in Fight Club, wo er das, glaube ich, ein paar Mal bei Fight Club war. Ui, die erste Regel. Das ist so uncool, wenn man das sagt, ne? Das ist so uncool. Und dann ist Ed Norton in diesem Meeting und trifft sich gerade mit... Ed, bist du schon beim Ed? Ich bin schon beim Ed, ja. Und ja, also Ed ist dann in dem Meeting und alle halt im Business-Anzug und sitzen da und reden über Marketing. Und er ist halt innerlich komplett zerstört, blaues Auge, und dann bluten seine Zähne, so sein Mundblut. Zähne, geblutet. Zähne, geblutet. Ja, oh Gott, das wäre nicht. Und dann fletscht er halt so seine Zähne dem Kollegen entgegen. Und das ist auch so ein schöner Moment, wo dieses rohe Animalische auf das Zivilisatorische trifft. Auf jeden Fall, die Geschichte geht noch weiter, aber behaltet im Hinterkopf meine Hände geblutet. Und dann war ich am Hauptbahnhof angekommen in Köln und dann laufe ich da so durch die Gegend und läuft plötzlich so ein junger Typ neben mir und sagt so, hey, ich würde dich gerne einladen. Gibt er so die Hand? Er sagt so, ich würde dich gerne einladen. Und ich dachte mir halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, er hat mich erkannt oder so, würde mich gerne in seinen YouTube-Channel oder seinen Podcast einladen. Ich denke mir, geil, okay, klar, immer gerne. Das ist so uncool, du bist so arrogant. Ja mein Gott. Deine Gedanken sind ob du damit nicht rechnen würdest. Als ob du sich so meine Geburtstagsparty einladen würdest. Ja, wieso denn nicht? Er hat den Luftballon, alle die Klausnase auf. Er war acht Jahre alt, das kannst du dir auch vorstellen. Auf jeden Fall, ich dann so, ja, okay, cool, worum geht's. Und er meint dann so, ja, ich bin Verführungskünstler. Ach ja, gedacht, Alter, ist das jetzt wirklich... Naja, aber unscheiss, wenn du ein so guter Verführungskünstler bist, hätte ich da nicht schon Ja gesagt. Aber ich bin auch dazu... So gut bist du nicht. Ist es schon so weit, dass mich Leute auf der Strasse in der Öffentlichkeit ansprechen und sagen, hey, du brauchst Hilfe beim Flirten, bitte lass mich dir helfen, lass mich dich zu meinem Seminar einladen. Jetzt wollte er nämlich mich zu seinem Seminar einladen. Ich war dann schon so ein bisschen so, aha, sehe ich so aus, als würde ich es brauchen oder was? Und er so, nein, das kann jeder total gut gebrauchen, ein bisschen selbstsicherer werden, Selbstbewusstsein, bla bla bla. Und ich so, ja, cool, nee, danke. Und dann wollte er mir zum Abschied noch die Hand geben, aber meine Hände geblutet. Und dann, wo ich mir auch nur vorstellen kann, was der Typ einfach für einen Eindruck von mir gehabt hat. Aber sah der Typ wahnsinnig gut aus oder so? Meine Vorstellung ist, wenn man dann als Verführungskünstler wahnsinnig gut aussieht und dann einfach zu Leuten einlädt, ganz viele, ja, Seminar, Verführungskünstler, hh, hh, hh, lädt man ganz viele Leute ein, dann abends 18 Uhr, das Licht geht an im Saal, Verführungskünstler, betritt die Bühne und sagt einfach nur, ja, ihr braucht Aussehen und verlässt mich an die Bühne. Ja, genau. Wäre ganz gut, wenn ihr ausseht wie ich. Macht's gut. Ach gut, tschüss. Broschüren gibt's am Eingang. Aber ich fand das so eine lustige Situation, dieses, ja, okay, gut, mein Angebot wurde nicht angenommen, tschau, mach's gut, Hände geben und nicht. Und ich dann so, ja, ich bin gerade hingefallen, ich blute, ich kann dir nicht die Hand geben, einfach diese, ich bin gerade hingefallen, ich blute, wo der Typ sich auch gedacht hat, welchen Volkdeppen muss ich hier an Land gezogen haben, ich bin gerade hingefallen, aber da habe ich mir auch, also früher, als ich noch kleiner war und meine Oma, kurz vor dem Tod, oh Gott, da fällt man halt oft hin. Im Krieg. Im Alter fällt man halt einfach oft hin. Im Krieg fällt man auch, sagt man ja auch. Und als Kind fällt man auch oft hin. Aber wenn man irgendwann zwischen 16 und, sagen wir mal, 78 sagt, ich bin hingefallen, ist ein No-Go. Aber es ist gesellschaftlich nicht akzeptiert hinzufallen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und die Plastikkordel, das glaubt ihr keiner. Und du mit den 31 Jahren, dass du da hinfällst, glaubt dir niemand. Ja, und dann auch noch meine Hände bluten, ich kann nichts machen, meine Hände geblutet. Und dann, übrigens, oh, ihr könnt euch bald auf einen guten Gag freuen, auf meinem Instagram-Account. Mir ist nämlich ein guter visueller Gag eingefallen, den wollte ich dann umsetzen und habe mir dafür einen Chai Latte bei Starbucks gekauft.
Hast einen anderen Namen genannt und hat jemand Valentin draufgeschrieben
auf dem Becher und das ist der ganze Gag.
Und habe da ein Foto
von dem gemacht und dann fand ich es so gut
und in dem Moment war der
Verführungskünstler ist überall durch den Bahnhof gelaufen
und genau in dem Moment
Stalking nennt man das auch,
Verführungskunst, aka Stalking. Und genau in dem Moment, in dem er mir entgegengelaufen ist, habe ich gerade ein Foto von meinem Starbucks-Bächer gemacht, was erstens so dieses klassische Hipster-Rige ist, aber halt dieser Starbucks-Bächer in meiner blutigen Hand und ich fotografiere meine blutige Hand, ich fand es auch wieder so peinlich. Es geht ein Augenrollen durch die Podcast-Ufo-Gemeinde gerade. Ich fand es so pein, dass dieser Podcast-Ufo-Typ genau in dem Moment an mir vorbeigelaufen ist. Naja. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber... Sehr guter Anfang. Ich hätte auch so anfangen müssen. Ne, aber ich glaube wirklich, dass man, das haben wir ja auch schon oft gesagt, dass Comedy einen so ein bisschen kaputt macht. Also auch gerade, wie du sagst, im Fallen, wo man dann vielleicht eher daran denken sollte, gut, wie schütze ich mich jetzt? Ich falle gerade hin, bin ich verhindert, versichert, solche Fragen sollte man sich dann stellen. Man denkt aber darüber nach, das ist gerade sehr unwahrscheinlich, was mir passiert. Genau wie ich mich dann abends mal im Bett befand und über mir die Nachbarn haben Radau gemacht, sind wie mit Steppschuhen durch die Wohnung gelaufen und dann habe ich, anstatt mich wie ein normaler Mensch darüber aufzuregen, saß ich da und habe mir einen Tweet darüber überlegt. Da dachte ich mir, das ist gerade perfekt, was dir passiert, du erlebst was, du machst es, du musst dafür nichts machen, lass die machen da oben, lass die Radau machen. Die Welt liefert die die Fälle ein. Dann saß ich da und dachte mir so, ja okay, die Blue Man Group ist über die eingezogen, geprobt oder sowas und dann dann die ganze Zeit habe ich mir überlegt, aber das ist ja das Falsche eigentlich. Sollte man sich darüber aufregen, sollte man wie ein normaler Mensch da hochgehen und sagen, ey, muss ich machen laute Geräusche, ich will auch schlafen, vielleicht mal. Es ist 21 Uhr, so, aber man macht es dann nicht. Es ist 13 Uhr. Stefan Ditzel liegt im Bett draußen, schall die Sonne weit aufgerissen. Augen liegt er im Bett und sagt, komm Welt, gib mir was. Weit grinsen, sitze ich da drin. Nee. Hast du schon mal einen Parabellogen? Ja. Echt? Tatsächlich in der Beichte sogar. Vielleicht sind wir deswegen da, wo wir sind. Damals im Religionsunterricht sollten wir auch mal in die Kirche gehen und beichten. Du bist katholisch auch, ne? Ja, ich habe mir tatsächlich eine schlimmere Sünde ausgedacht, als ich sie hatte. Weil ich meine Sünden so langweilig fand. Ich auch. Dass ich mir eine schlimmere Sünde ausgedacht habe. Was ja eigentlich nur die noch grössere... Nein, aber was hast du wirklich damals so gemacht, was Schlimmes war, was wir beichten können? Ich habe mich mit meinen Brüdern gestritten. Das war es halt. Gestritten. Gestritten. Und du hast Tiere getötet wahrscheinlich als Kind, töte man Tiere. Ja, wir haben Fisch erschossen. So, okay. Mir ist es mal eingefallen, neulich auch irgendwie, da habe ich drüber nachgedacht, was kann ich mal hier erzählen für lustige Geschichten, wenn wir mal in einer Situation, wenn wir uns mal in einer lustigen Situation befinden, in dieser tragischen Situation, dass wir wieder nichts zu erzählen haben. Und dann ist mir diese Geschichte eingefallen. Ich habe damals nämlich für eine Projektarbeit im Philosophieunterricht, da sollten wir uns Themen aussuchen, ich habe mir das Thema ausgesucht, Wissenschaft versus Religion. Also, ist noch in der modernen Wissenschaft Platz für Gott und so. Aber wirklich, aber ist noch nicht so jung und noch nicht so alt. Da hat man sich ja trotzdem schon ein paar Gedanken gemacht. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, ich gehe zu einem Priester und interviewe den. Dann habe ich auch aber einen Wissenschaftler interviewt, vom CERN sogar damals, mega cool. Und dann habe ich aber auch den Priester interviewt. Und du kannst die nicht so wirklich ernst interviewen, weil du die ganze Zeit denkst, das sind ja schon die nettesten Menschen, die es so gibt auf der Welt. Priester sind schon wahnsinnig nett. Und dann habe ich, da saß ich davor und dachte mir so, und dann wollte ich die ganze Zeit fragen, ist denn da noch Platz für Gott eigentlich in der modernen Wissenschaft? Und dann saß da dieser grinsende Mann in seiner spartanischen Wohnung vor mir über all die Bilder, wie er Häuser in Sarajevo wieder aufbaut und so. Das kannst du nicht fragen. Und dann hat er das Interview irgendwie an sich gerissen, war dann gefragt, glaubst du denn an Gott? Und dann sitzt du da, schreibst eine Arbeit darüber, dass es keinen Gott geben kann und sagst dann ja einfach, na klar, na klar. Dann ist mir auch klar geworden, du belügst gerade einen Pfarrer.
Das ist schlimm. Du belügst gerade, also wenn es dann
einen Gott gibt, du landest so fucking in der Hölle.
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
dann habe ich die Geschichte erzählt, wie ich
damals in der Pfarrschule saß,
bei der theoretischen Prüfung
und
eine Frage nicht wusste
ist ja sehr unwahrscheinlich,
dass am Neben-PC gerade genau die gleiche Frage erscheint.
Und am Neben-PC
ist genau die gleiche Frage erschienen
und die wusste es auch, die Person.
Also es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich,
es ist wirklich sehr unwahrscheinlich,
es gibt so ganz viele Fragen.
Dann habe ich diese Frage aber auch
abgespäht, konnte es sogar noch sehen,
weil es genau der PC neben mir war, dann war es mir richtig peinlich dann. Aber er hat gesagt, ja, das ist Gott. Whatever, man, whatever works for you. Hat mich aber nachträglich noch sehr beeindruckt. Dankeschön. Das war Stefan Netze mit seiner Anekdote, der Herr in der Fahrschule. Das Problem könnte auch sein, dass wir heute auf Couches sitzen. Jeder hat eine Couch und wir liegen, befleht uns hier so rum. Und dass ich direkt auf der Aufnahme zwei Hotels gegessen habe. Es gibt so viele Gründe, warum diese Folge nicht so gut geworden ist. Aber allen voran ist es der Grund, dass wir uns den ganzen Tag schon gesehen haben und uns nicht mehr zu viel zu erzählen haben. Ja. Und wir letzte Folge eine gute Folge rausgekommen haben und nächste Woche ein Special Guest kommt. Nächste Woche kommt ein Special Guest, das ist erstmal Sommerpause, ein bisschen, weil ich eine Woche lang in Urlaub fahre. Und danach kommt aber die Knallerfolge. Magst du mal erzählen, wohin du fährst? Ach, ist gar nicht ganz unspektakulär, Ich fahre an See mit meinen Freunden wie jedes Jahr und ich werde mir ein
fünf Minuten Stand-Up-Programm zurechtlegen.
Das sage ich jetzt hier, weil dann kann ich nicht mehr zurückziehen.
Ich sage hier, ich werde mir für nächste
Folge ein fünf Minuten Stand-Up-Programm
zurechtlegen und es vor Maxi Gschettenbauer
präsentieren. Das sind verraten.
Unironisch und ohne...
Man kann schlechter Gäste nicht an die sein.
Nein, aber es ist ja...
Alle, die auf Twitter aktiv sind, wissen das ja schon. Alle nicht. Tatsächlich Maxii Geschittenbauer wird in die nächste Folge kommen, hoffentlich. Gott, die sind cool. Und ich werde es nicht ironisch machen, also sollte ich es ironisch machen, werdet ihr jetzt wissen, dass es eigentlich nicht ironisch gemeint ist, von wegen, na ja, das ist ja alles total schlecht und ach, es ist ja bla bla bla, sondern ich will das schon ernsthaft machen und ich will gucken, wie ihr reagiert, ich will gucken, wie ihr reagiert und ich will gucken, ob ich eine Karriereoption Stand-Up-Comedian habe, ja oder nein. Und alle, die sich diese Folge angehört haben, werden die Antwort bereits kennen. Sie lautet, nein, Florentin hat keine Zukunft im Bereich Stand-Up. Maxi, sowohl der andere Gast, der noch kommen wird, als auch ich, sind der Meinung, dass Florentin seine Karriere dann erstell begraben sollte und lieber eine Art Podcast-Netzwerk gründen sollte, wo er dann klar macht, dass seine Zukunft da liegt und eigentlich auch die Zukunft Deutschlands im Medienbereich. Das waren Florian und Stefan von
das Podcast UFO. Vielen Dank
fürs Zuhören. Sie hatten gerade Stefan
Titze. Mein Name ist Florian Will.
Wir wünschen Ihnen weiterhin einen schönen Tag.
Bis dahin. Und eine schöne Woche.
Machen Sie es gut. Tschüss. Ciao. Das war eine schlechte Folge, ich bin ein bisschen sentimental, aber wenn man bedenkt, dass jede Folge eine Funken Wahrheit trägt, dann war das die Offenbarung des Florentin W. und Stefan T.
In unserem Herzen funkelt ein Rubin, wunderschön und hell erleuchtet sitzt er dort im Regen. Mit Stefan Tietze in der Hand und Florentin auf einem Weg laufen sie durch die Stadt Hand in Hand. Stefan und Florentin und der Rubin erleben ein Abenteuer. Sie gehen ins Phantasialand und fahren mit der Black Mamba zehn Runden, nachdem sie sich in dreiviertel Stunde angestellt haben. Der Rubin ist eine Metapher, das habt ihr bestimmt schon erraten, wofür allerdings, das werden wir euch nicht verraten, weil wir es selbst nicht wissen, weil wir es selbst nicht wissen, weil wir es selbst nicht wissen. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Funschild für Spaß, und ich glaube, wir geben jetzt Gas, der Florentin ist am Start, er weiss, wie es geht, ich glaube, wir gehen, wie er steht. Podcast Ufo ist jetzt gelandet, wir wollen nicht, dass ihr in der Runde bestrandet. Salz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer, Salz, Rubin, rote Augen, hat Stefan um den Hals.
Das war der Rapper, er hat etwas freote Augen, hat Stefan um den Hals.
Das war der Rappart, er hat etwas fremd in dem Lied gewirkt.
Doch es ist kein Problem, denn es ist der Sinn von Rappart, wenn der Song nicht drei Minuten trägt.